we'll never have Paris this was written
by co-directed and stars your best
friend probably in the world Simon
Helberg of the Big Bang Theory yeah and
there's the two you are and he really
you know we we know him well because
they shoot literally fifteen feet from
here yeah if you watch Big Bang Theory
as you can often hear Andy and I in the
background talking it's doing this show
cuz you can hit it with a tennis ball
and so I asked sign about you and he
said the thing to ask you about was the
fact that you cannot say no to a dare
that's what he says yeah that's it's one
of my problems and he figured this out
pretty early on in our friendship we
were a college roommates and he realized
that I I have this sort of perfect
combination of competitiveness and and
I'm also very gullible mm-hm so if he
wanted something he would just go hey I
bet you can't make it all the way to the
vending machine and back in two minutes
with a coke for me I bet you can't go
and then I run I like just decide if I
could take the stairs of the elevator
fly down this is very dangerous and then
I get back up boom did I make it and he
go I wasn't really timing but thank
seemed like you're like a dog well it
was a little bit like that if he asked
me to do it I wouldn't do it but as soon
as he put like a time limit IC challenge
the minute its I bet you cannot do it
you're capable of doing yeah or I dare I
dare you works the same way it's some
it's there's a there's a couple things
missing here guys yeah it's it's almost
like an obsessive-compulsive disorder
where you have to do it it is it is
because what what if I don't do it and I
was supposed to do it you know tongue
stuck to a lot of flack Paul's in you're
a kid I stuck my tongue to a lot of
flagpoles but I'd never got them stuck
not that you should all try and I think
that is a real thing but I guess I had
enough saliva to not this is I don't
know what the hell happened to this
conversation
I have a lot of gay helots this say this
tongue touched every flagpole in town it
sounds filthy and horrible certainly and
he also said that I'm supposed to ask
you about the Pacific Coast Highway
story because if it was highway the very
busy highway that runs along this
beautiful Pacific Coast which is fake
right here
yes but it's still beautiful oh yeah
that was a night where we were baby 16
or 17 and we found ourselves at the
beach late at night we had walked there
this is you and in science Simon and a
couple of my other friends and we
decided that we wanted to go swimming in
the ocean but we were trying to think
ahead and we're like we don't want to
walk back home and wet clothes so I went
I have the solution and I whip my boxers
off ran in and then before I put it all
all your clothes off you went swimming
naked I went swimming they get rolled
here too it's cold and it's not a play
don't go swimming in the ocean at night
it's it's very very cold and and painful
but before I put on my clothing anyone
here wanted to do that don't do that
thing where you set your legs on fire
and so I I put my I put two piles of
clothes on either side of PCH and I
realized that this would be the only
time that I would ever have a chance to
do this and I ran across PCH naked a
bunch of times to retrieve your clothes
yeah I would go here put on a sock go
back to the other one put on my boxers
go to the other one get I think that's
the dumbest thing I've ever heard
anybody doing Pacific Coast Highway is
so well-traveled that's what I mean it's
I can't imagine crossing it once but you
were running back and forth naked it was
me the one in the car that hit you
laughing I brought you back together
thank you
you